a uno de los presentadores estrella de
la cadena británica y que recordaba
leyenda del fútbol inglés volverá este
fin de semana a su programa match of the
day el cual dirige desde 1999 línea
quiere el rostro mejor pago de la bbc
había sido suspendido el viernes como
consecuencia de un tweet en el que
criticaba la política americaratoria del
gobierno del Reino Unido incluyendo una
comparativa con la Alemania nazine la
bbc se apegó a su política de
imparcialidad para tomar la decisión de
suspenderlo una decisión que desató una
oleada de críticas contra este medio
acusándolo de ceder ante la presión del
gobierno del Premier Richie que expresó
en manos de su ejecutivo su rechazo a
ese tweet de lineal hoy la cadena
anunció una revisión de sus directrices
para redes sociales para empleados
independientes para así llegar a este
acuerdo para que regrese lineaker dice
Team David director general de la bbc
que defiende haber suspendido a alguien
Y que ahora escuchemos
lo que hemos acordado y he compartido
tiempo hablando con Gary hemos tenido
muchas discusiones entre ahora y para
cuando se emita el reporte Gary va a
cumplir la directriz editorial y ahí es
donde nos encontramos
por su parte eléctrica que fue goleador
del Mundial de 1986 con Inglaterra
expresó estar encantado con su regreso
para aquellos que no hayan visto a línea
y carlyker es una persona con muchísimo
carisma su programa ese programa es un
programa de resumen de análisis de
mostrar lo que ocurre en la jornada de
fútbol de fin de semana es un programa
muy popular en la cadena bbc además
liker es un experto en compartir esa
experiencia que él tuvo como delantero
como goleador como jugador para
transmitírselo a la gente como
presentador y ahora nos Abre también un
espacio de debate Juan que nos plantea
el oficio mismo que estamos realizando